welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we've been
watching The Watchmen to break down
everything that you need to know about
the full season on HBO after the huge
twist that blew our minds last week it's
time to visit the doctor and see how
angela met the guy named after the
world's biggest dildo and yeah I still
can't get over their ex Carl a bar
Easter egg throughout this video we're
gonna be going over the entire episodes
plot and discussing the huge revelations
in it there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
the latest entry yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
click in this video now let's get into
our breakdown a watchman episode 8 okay
so episode 8 is just a massive trip
through time that shows how the past
influences the future but also a due to
dr. Manhattan's powers how the future
influences the past as they say it's
very much a chicken and the egg
situation and for those who don't know a
dr. Manhattan can see every single
moment of his life at the exact same
time he knows what will happen in the
future in the past and in the past knows
what will happen in the future
Allen wanted to create a character who
was aware that time was cyclical and
also show that in knowing what would
happen in the future how you would be
tied to it forced to live out every
moment watching all play out the way
that it was supposed to I think like the
best way to describe it is that imagine
if you watched episode 3 of Watchmen
first then episode 7 then went back to
one he would kind of have this knowledge
of what would be happening but the
episodes themselves would be reordered
still they would possess the same
narrative though and thus you would be
able to fit together all of the pieces
in between yeah it's difficult to
explain but that's probably the best
analogy for that can think of anyway
this episode exemplifies what it would
be like to fall in love with someone who
knows everything sounds like my
ex-girlfriend that you haven't that dr.
Manhattan is a God who is all-powerful
all-knowing and one that doesn't age
this episode though it really humanizes
dr. Manhattan
through one of our most human emotions
love and it shows how that can change
someone turning the God into a man Cal
was able to accomplish this by losing
his abilities and this is about
reinstating them in order to save the
world episode 8 God walks into a bar
aka a god dr. Manhattan walks into a bar
as in Angela a bar has shown from the
docs perspective and like the graphic
novel it follows a similar aesthetic of
jumping back and forth that unveil the
entire plan and how everything fits
together it opens in Saigon and we see a
bit of blue dick Rafi and then doc walks
into Eddie's bar toned down and wearing
a mask to fit in with everyone he picks
up two beers and this mirrors John's
first meeting with Janey Slater and the
graphic novel in which she bought him
one he said it was the first time a girl
did that for him and it was a big moment
where their fingers touched as she
handed over the glass the dock shows up
and just completely blows Angela away
almost talking in riddles and this
comparisons to Zeus coming down to make
love with the malls we learned that the
vision of Manhattan we saw on Mars in
Episode one it's just a decoy carrying
out predetermined paths and that the
dock has been on Europa creating a
utopia that we know Ozzy would later end
up living on at the end of the Watchmen
graphic novel doc did say he was going
to go off into the universe and create
life there however we get the feeling
that it was just too perfect to ever
feel real and thus he abandoned it
anyway now we know that doc created it
this is why us he made the body say save
me D and it also explains why us he
wanted to leave and I love how there
were actually some similarities with the
two that are never really thought of
John lived on earth and ended up leaving
it in the graphic novel because he was
just sick of being caught up in the
mundane 'ti of it and Ozzy who lived on
Europa to wish to leave because he
became bored
we watched the miracle maker walk on
water and create Adam and Eve or rather
mr. Phillips and Miss Cruikshank when he
was younger doc or rather John saw the
two the real versions of them getting it
on and they became large influences on
him passing him a blue Bible that made
him learn about God and how he created
life which will go on to influence his
actions down the line
they instill in him the promise to
return to the castle with the Bible once
he has created something beautiful and
he fulfills this in his actions on
Europa
he also recreates the castle up they
lived in which was a huge part of his
early life throughout the episode Doc's
actual faces hidden and this keeps the
character separate from kal and also
means that fans of the graphic novel
don't have their prior image of the
character changed instead all we ever
see really is Angela's reaction to him
as she tries to tempt him to reveal his
powers Angela says she hates dr.
Manhattan because looking back he
basically changed the world causing the
events that would lead to her parents
deaths and as we know the Watchmen
universe vastly diverse from the one
that we inhabit from the Vietnam War
onwards Angela also mentions how the
bomber that killed her parents was a
puppeteer that wanted to hold the
strings and this is a reference to the
graphic novel in which dr. Manhattan
when discussing his ability to view time
says we are all puppets I can just see
the strings this is very much shaped her
perception just how Doc's perception was
shaped by his powers he was burdened by
what the world wanted him to be and what
they thought of him but inside he was
crying out to be human doc just wants to
have dinner with Angela but she says
that he won't be able to blend in so
they go and visit the morgue and Angela
reluctantly chooses a corpse named
Calvin that she wants him to transform
into she clearly has some attraction to
him but won't admit it to herself due to
him being dead but John still takes his
form now what the episode is excellently
is that it shows how the two end up
falling in love but it also sets a
deadline on their relationship of ten
years and we know that it will come to a
tragic end it kind of fits in to the
regrets thing in which John say said he
regrets Vietnam but how we also end up
doing things that we know we will regret
anyway John's biggest issue is that he
can never be in the moment and that
Angela hates how much he is tied to fate
there's also another Easter Egg for the
graphic novel when Angela asks when's
the last time he was afraid and similar
to the book he discusses his
transformation in the intrinsic field as
predicted Angela asks him to leave and
he's devastated
this kinda shows the complexity of the
character as he can still feel the
emotional weight of moments even if he
knows what's going to happen in advance
he visits Ozymandias in Karnak who
similar to his home on europa has
smashed the place up watching as the
world he wished to create didn't come to
fruition as he knows that humans will
always be driven to create weapons and
yet Cal is packing a weapon let me tell
you ladies any way we see the to
reminisce over old times and we also see
Ozzy is the one who creates the squid
falls in order to maintain world peace
he's been running them manually from his
home keeping up the lie as he draws the
conclusion that doc has fallen in love
and thus has changed himself like my ex
try it changed me I said are you having
that we discovered that as he created
the device that stops dark seeing the
entirety of his life and that this is
made of tachyons I thought this would be
the case last time but here holds a lot
more weight in the episode as we
discover it's pretty much his kryptonite
and it means that the character does
actually have a weakness before moving
on the plan cow goes to visit will and
through Angela asking questions informs
him that Jude is a member of Cyclops and
about his robe this of course shows how
he knew ahead of time and how he was
able to inform true that doc was in
Tulsa and who he was as he had seen the
characters new appearance he also knows
that dr. manhattan's tied to his
granddaughter so yeah it just puts the
pieces of the puzzle together really
nicely will lives and captain metropolis
his old pad and the to form and aligns
to contact Angela and also look after
their children on the night that the 7th
cavalry come Angela believes that she
started all but as mentioned earlier the
past is the future and the future is the
past and so on it's chicken in the egg
as he makes a deal with the doctor move
to the utopia on Europa wishing to
escape due to his great failings on
earth it's a really emotional scene that
I think grounds Ozzy quite a lot I
always kind of looked at its character
as being slightly underdeveloped but
here Jeremy Irons really knocks out the
park
so yeah Theory confirmed doc created the
world for Z and there's potential at
dock also told true when Ozzy would
return and this is why she bought the
farm at the start of episode 4 as he
could also be trues father
if the comedian is not and she could
have been cased a character in gold
which is what she was referring to when
she mentioned bringing her mother and
father to see the completion of her
clock
Angela puts the Tachyon device in the
cow and together they moved to Tulsa the
location that she never got to see after
the death
of her grandma we also learned that da
can pass on his powers through someone
eating them which I think will play a
big part in the show going forward
perhaps Angela will get them but it also
shows that geo keen may be able to get
them through this method which i think
is what's gonna likely happen
finally after 43 minutes we catch up to
the moment that left last week on a
devastating cliffhanger the seven
cavalry are coming for John and all
Angela can do is defend him John
throughout this just feels so lost weary
from what's going on and kind of tied to
the inevitability of it all we also
learn that it was Kyle that saved Angela
on the white knight as theorised and he
seems completely nonchalant about the
incoming attack Angela tries to stop
them but as we know she can't save him
it is a great action scene but yeah one
that's ultimately doomed to end in
tragedy
John intervenes to save Angela but as we
know this won't work the cavalry used
the tachyonic cannon to transport dog to
their headquarters and were left
wondering what will happen to him now
well John died hmm I don't think so and
people have failed to kill the character
in the past which I think will be
repeated here personally I actually
believe that jokey may even succeed in
his plan with John passing on his powers
as mentioned in the episode however he
will gain a perception like dr.
Manhattan and then become completely
removed from his fuse and gold's due to
the detachment that possessing the
powers of John will carry if tachyons
can defeat the doc and they can likely
defeat Joe and I think the weapons had
he created for Doc will be turned on him
in order to defeat him also in case he
didn't stick around for the post-credits
scene in that we see Ozzy being punished
for trying to escape they squashed
tomatoes in his face and we learned that
by two suffers with the utopias
perfection he wants to be needed the
game warden visits him and gives him
another anniversary cake but it has a
horseshoe in the bottom it looks like
the clones are slowly getting things
wrong and we did see in the premiere
that they gave him one instead of a
knife so yeah this is a nice callback to
that we also learned that the game
warden was in fact the original mr.
Phillips anyway using the horseshoe Ozzy
is gonna Shawshank his way out of the
cell and finally make a break for it
I do think Ozzy will return and having
reached out to the doc perhaps be
transported back to earth which is where
we will see him land on the farm where
he was picked
by true this show is gonna reveal it all
soon enough and hopefully this time next
week we finally have all of the answers
to everything
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode and if you agree
with the theories in this video comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this then please give it a thumbs up
make sure you stay locked to the channel
for more watchmen breakdowns as the
series begins to wrap up we'd be
discussing every episode so it's
definitely worth keeping locked into
heavy spoilers for the finale we also do
a podcast called watching The Watchmen
in which we break down the original
graphic novel issue by issue so if you
want to know the full backstory in the
book that make sure you check it out
after this you want to come chat to me
after the video then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which would be linked in the description
below we drop videos on there early so
if you want to see stuff before anyone
else and that's the best place to be
it's free adjoining we have been awesome
communities so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 2
box on blu-ray which contains Black
Panther infinity war and Game Captain
Marvel or more and all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like
the video make 'shy subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts and
watchmen in the comment section below
the one it's gonna be chosen on the 15th
of a December and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised so best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]